okay
okay these are the questions uh andrew
yang and a group of former uh republican
and democratic officials announced their
new centrist political party
uh i think david jolly's involved with
that i saw their uh brief
announcement of this and they said um
other third parties haven't worked
here's why ours will right do you think
they can become a viable third party
who is that too
that's to all of your us
ah you want to take it well the one
thing that i
um
why is that tough no why is that such a
hot potato jamel in the new york times
has a very skeptical piece about this
and it's all well taken but i think that
we also forget that a lot of these
things are driven by personality and
charisma and there are only so many
lessons you can take from 1850 because
we have something called social media
and so i think all bets are off at this
point i think that the idea is valuable
it's clearly urgent and i think that we
need to see whether things could happen
on the basis of unpredictables history
can't teach us everything i just
piggyback and add two things one is it
requires a lot of money okay
and the other thing to your point about
personality you need someone who's
dynamic who can cross appeal
uh so it could work and by work i mean
it could siphon off enough votes to
affect the election if you had an
extremely rich person with you know
dynamic personality
who did it uh but i don't know you know
michael bloomberg could have done it but
he chose to run in the democratic party
so there's probably a reason for that
you need more of a personality then
michael bloomberg
[Applause]
they've actually had personable people
run before it's not that it's that
when when a third party starts doing
well yes one of the other two parties
steals
what made them popular and adopts it
right they were you know ross perot did
pretty well
and i think the republicans stole his
thunder a little bit you know on debt
and stuff they of course didn't follow
through they're the biggest dead
hypocrites in the world but you know and
we had other ones back um wasn't um
well i think the problem on the left is
that there's like this trauma lingering
from ralph nader right like you
the idea that a third party would come
in siphon off a couple thousand votes
and you'd have a florida 20 2000 redux
is you know panic fuel for a lot of
progressives and so you're more likely
obviously to get something in the
centrist who would peel off moderate
republicans
but democrats are fearful of that
because they need those people to leave
the republican party and support them so
that there's a lot of incentives that
work again but it is an interesting
dynamic about how much [ __ ] people are
full of
because it won't work
because and it people are really as
chris was saying they are more in the
middle and there is this hunger this
thirst for something that isn't and yet
when push comes to shove and they get in
the voting booth i don't know if it's
whether the attack ads work on them or
they just think that that party will
lose they don't want to vote for a loser
but they don't follow up they don't
follow on those convictions i think a
lot of it is the i think i mean
political advertisement is you know
geared around
creating a whole culture of fear of the
opposition i mean that is it's potent
it's targeted and it's persuasive i do
think though you know the one sort of
caveat is that like you know
joe biden's not a radical i mean he's
not he's just not and he was put forward
as a democratic nominee precisely
because he bends into the radical he has
been yes and i think that's part of
that's part of what's been a problem for
mr president is that he's raised these
expectations by you know saying yeah
let's do all this this two trillion
dollar bill social media makes all this
different though and i think that yes
there's a possibility that social media
could create a furor a united group of
people constantly whipped up to stay
together who were actually in this
middle it would be a matter of branding
but maybe those forces that for example
kept perrault as a marginal figure could
actually make a difference this time
because of what twitter in particular is
like it really creates a whole new world
it would depend on the branding and the
charisma but i can imagine that maybe it
would be different this time because of
these things in our pockets and the way
it unites groups together it can create
a new group in other words well i think
what would happen my prediction is you
could have it like a sensible middle
party
and it would then what would happen is
it would force the democrats
to go back to being the sensible middle
party
and they would because they would see
that's where you know biden i mean biden
reminds me of some
grandfather and when when aoc and the
woke people come into his office and
he's just he just goes along he doesn't
really understand it it's like grandpa
can we have money to go play fortnite
and
and he's like
yeah just take i don't know what
fortnite is i don't know what tick-tock
is
just get out of my hair you know and
that's really
okay
nearly one in three americans say it may
soon be necessary to take up arms
against the government ish
pro or con
[Laughter]
is this an indication
is this is this an indicator that we're
already in a cold civil war well i would
say we already are yes what does this
tell us about the next presidential
election how often were people asked
about that particular thing before
that's a genuine question now you would
be inclined to put that in a poll where
people asked in 1951 are you ready to
take arms against the government i
imagine many more people would have said
yes then really and we can know now what
was their big beef against the
government imagine there would have been
people who were very angry at for
example still angry at franklin d
roosevelt still angry at inequality in
the system right there's a great deal of
anger yeah you're right i mean the
civil rights movement right i mean the
60s were there were people angry for
incredible anger obviously assassination
there was a lot of talk before kennedy
got assassinated about
that
this is a common american thread lunatic
a very despicable american threat you
know obviously we've never experienced a
president sort of harnessed the degree
that trump has and i think that's what
makes this kind of a unique moment but
it's been with us throughout our history
for sure uh okay why isn't biden more
aggressive on legalizing marijuana
yeah
what i mean
why is that why is that the one issue
when the grandkids come in and say
grandpa can we have some money to
legalize
i wrote about this because this is crazy
to me at a time when he's experiencing
like an incomplete enthusiasm deficit on
the left here's an issue where it's like
80 of the country's like yes
legalize this [ __ ] just do it and he's
like uh we need to study it
it's um it's low-hanging
now the actual reasons the actual
reasons and i'm not saying i'm not
saying i believe them the actual reasons
are is that he
has a history of addiction in his family
and he actually believes that's what it
is that marijuana has a gateway protect
which it doesn't of course it's hunter
yes and that's i don't but he thinks
hunter started on the pot
it's a real it's a real belief that he
helps right and i'm sure we did but so
what we all start somewhere and of
course
that came out wrong
that's not what i meant
but i mean that beer is a gateway drug
you know if you're if you're going to be
hunter biden it's not the marijuana you
can't stop everyone versus marijuana
because one out of so many people is
going to wind up that but it's like and
the other thing that it was that i
wanted to write about this is that it's
not like biden hasn't touched sort of
socially progressive hot topics before i
mean he was the guy in 2012 yep who came
out and said let's do gay marriage and
everyone's at times like that is nuts
what are you doing you're going to lose
ohio this is crazy right i said [ __ ] it
i'm gonna do it
well it wasn't that was not quite that
intentional is my recollection well
everything's a little bit intentional he
didn't go in there being like you know
what maybe i'll just throw out that i
support gay marriage yeah i think he did
really yeah
he was talking about somebody specific
and he was just doing what he does riffs
and he you know he he was just riffing
and then the next day in the office like
what did you do
we were backing marriage his experience
he has an experience knowing that it
doesn't backfire right he could do it
with pop but he doesn't so sam is it
really true that there are people from
states all over the country there's a
question sure states from all over the
country there's this ground swell to
legalize marijuana and then hopefully go
further if you ask me and the president
has actually said that he's not
interested because of the family issues
in his conviction he is he is our
reporting is that he has conveyed this
to his aides that he is nervous about
his own family's experience his current
platform is decriminalization which
obviously is different than legalization
and there's a lot of people in the party
who really think legitimately that this
could be one of those issues that's so
low-hanging could energize people yeah
it would just if you just got it out of
the way and we'd look back and be like
what were we and it would be a social
revolution and by the way it's already
de facto in effect of course how do i
know this i used to travel this country
so paranoid
i would put a little bit of
marijuana i don't know what i'm aware
[Laughter]
no not there
under my nuts really
there was a little thing that was like
it looked like half of a cigarette it
was a metal it was just a tube that's
all you need to smoke through and i only
needed like this much i took one bud put
in a kleenex under my nuts
and i was ready if they said what is
this
what we gonna say i was gonna say
it's not
meaning the pot and then if they caught
me
i said it's snot
i had that ready that's how paranoid i
was and you don't still do that just for
schizophrenia and now
like and then there was a phase where
i'd be like oh what states is it legal
what can i i don't even think about it
because even if it's a state where it's
illegal are they really going to make a
good thing about a thing under i don't
care
and i was like
i just put in my nuts because i like it
thank you everybody
[Applause]
you